let's jump to this next story from
timcast.com democrats call supreme court
illegitimate
urge resistance following abortion
decisions because they didn't know this
is uh this is a story uh from adrian
norman from tim cast rep maxine waters
told protesters to hell with the supreme
court we will defy them aoc was yelling
illegitimate and um
i should say urging resistance
you mean urging insurrection and
violence now as much as i will jokingly
say urging insurrection and it's i'm
making a point by saying it i do
appreciate that at timecast.com we don't
use that loaded language but um the
point i'm making when i say insurrection
is these democrats are coming out right
now and and saying no to the supreme
court and more importantly and maybe you
can comment on this more uh will
the doj garland came out and rebuked
both the gun decision and roe v wade
when does the doj do that it it doesn't
that's not its job right the doj has it
has it ever come out and announced it
would defy or resist never seen in doj
independently make announcements and
pronounce on like how you know that it
how much it disagreed with the supreme
court decision like that's that's new to
me maybe maybe i'm wrong but i don't
recall the trump doj under bar ever
doing anything like this
um and i think that's because that's the
role i mean it's it's supposed to it
it's there's two big reasons one is that
the doj is supposed to have this nominal
appearance of independence right like
they're the enforcers of the laws um the
people who make the decision about who
to prosecute whom not to prosecute so
like their them at least trying to
appear unbiased should be important
which is clearly they're just not and
then secondly you know they go in front
of the supreme court regularly i mean
the the us government is routinely a
litigant in front of the supreme court
defending its own laws
uh you know trying to also as amicus
likes making statements about other
cases that might implicate a federal
interest so
there's an importance for the doj itself
to have a somewhat like good you know
working relationship with the courts in
fact like the solicitor general is often
called like the 10th justice because
they're supposed they're so often in
front of the court and the idea that doj
would jeopardize that by just going you
know the attorney general being like
you're all wrong and you're idiots like
okay dude i mean that's
that could that actually breaking that
relationship and maybe it's good because
you want the government to lose in the
supreme court a lot but it's it's very
unique and bizarre well i thought
what you would have said there yeah i'm
putting more rights
i'm not going to stop celebrating it's
hard but you made this point you're
saying that it's uh
it could be great if the supreme court
just starts siding against the
government more often in my mind that's
fantastic yeah like i'm gonna make
another cake no here's i gotta run out
of cases i've got a question for
everybody slippery slope right so when
we were younger they would say well
people would say well if you allow gay
marriage then they're going to start
trying to groom your kids and if you
start to wait they're doing that yeah
all of everything the christian rights
said just turned out to be true but
continue so does so my question is is
the slippery slope not a fallacy right
if you look at abortion they said if you
allow abortion they're gonna say well
now it's no longer just safe legal you
know rare it's now gonna be all the way
up to nine months and maybe even a
couple of days after or like right after
there so
northam said make the baby the baby's
delivered made comfortable and then the
mother and the doctor have a
conversation conversation is had right
that's all here's the thing i'll say
slippery slope
it's not a fallacy it no and it never
was nope right i don't i don't think uh
i think
the idea that a slippery slope means you
it implies that you go off the rails
things go out of control sort of i view
it as
degrees incrementalization yeah it's not
a fallacy it's it's literally just
once the door is opened on say
two people can get married it's none of
your business then the question is under
that logic however you realize that like
an adult father could marry his daughter
right do you are you okay with that i
think that's kind of over the line and
then they can say okay but that one no
it's like hold on
if your argument is based on the idea
that two consenting adults
in in the privacy of their own home and
however they want to deal with their
lives should not be infringed upon then
why would that not open the door to
every other circumstance so how do we
put on the brakes right well that's the
thing because initially like i think if
two men want to get married they should
be free to do that right i don't think
the state should inhibit
that that behavior that's my own
personal view but how do you put the
brakes on once you've done something
like that and you safeguard or protect
that that it doesn't go off there's no
brakes yeah i don't think there are keep
your kids off the internet
my friend is a twenty one hundred
percent keeper
maybe not twenty four seven but pump the
brakes and super you know supervise if
they're gonna be there imagine imagine
letting your kid watch like skinamax or
like it it's unthinkable yeah but these
days parents are like i don't know i
don't think they're gonna i don't think
we're even worse than cinemax ever was i
don't think the gay marriage thing
directly resulted in the grooming of the
kids it seems like it's like a global
weird thing no no not an american ideal
it's uh it's it's simple an internet
when the christian right said if we have
gay marriage the next thing they're
gonna do is start teaching kids about it
in school and they said that's
ridiculous if two people are privately
living in their lives it's it's their
business but of course the logical
outcome is
well kids need to be taught about yes
legal precedent and about adults and how
they live right okay it should be in
school well yeah why we don't need
government schools well 100 but also on
top of that it's like how could you ever
possibly make the argument that society
is going to adopt a new value and not
pass that value onto its children
right that's what society does with its
values that's like so it's the point
instead of like oh no yeah we'll
legalize gay marriage but like we're not
going to start telling kids about it
we're not going to start teaching kids
about being gay et cetera that's just a
ridiculous position i don't know how
anyone argued that with a straight so i
i think one of the the next uh possible
changes
is
the end of gender gender segregation
yeah because under the same arguments
made i was reading about the civil
rights stuff um and the arguments they
made about the end of racial segregation
and the funny thing is
and i'll say this is this the argument
the left makes the same arguments made
about gender segregation were made for
racial segregation people were arguing
that black and white people were
fundamentally like very different that
you know black people had this thing
about them or what about this thing so
it makes sense to separate this is the
argument again i'm saying presented by
the left as to why they should end
gender segregation they said under the
1964 civil rights act that says you
can't uh discriminate in public
accommodation they end segregation but
why do we still have gender-based
segregation in that case
so
it's not a slippery slope it's literally
moral logic follows so what do you do
with gay kids right so when i was a
child you know i have a gay brother you
know we're kids we're looking at the
series magazine and i'm flipping to the
girls section and he's like flipping to
the guys section and we didn't know what
sex was right so who talks to them about
that right who you know without that
being considered your parents grooming
right like parents your parents decide
how to address it and that's right but i
mean likely matter you know if they
don't have parents right if there's if
there's no third party right that's like
the moral legitimate you know person who
is supposed to be doing that whose
responsibility is it to explain why this
child is feeling the feelings that
they're feeling that may not be the same
as the rest of the kids in their class
how where do they where does some third
party have a moral right to have a
conversation with that child about what
they're feeling if nobody else does they
have no parents they have a guardian
right right well there you go okay so
they're just the guardian the guardian
yeah could they be accused of you know
grooming if they don't have the proper
relationship i don't
well
um if if you are not the the guardian or
parent of a child and then you're trying
to introduce adult sexual concepts to
them yeah i take issue with that because
i don't trust it well and also like it
is absolutely the case that parents or
guardians can and do groom children
right but right now but but i think we
can say as a blanketed case people who
are not the parent or guardian should
not under any circumstances be having
these conversations with children no
there's a circumstance in which the
parents agree that they want an educator
or someone to talk to their kids about
it so you know my attitude with the
florida bill
is
some of these conversations are already
inappropriate for kids yeah if the
parents decide my child is old enough to
start learning about these things the
parent decide what's best for their kids
if that means they have a third party
educator i disagree with it but that's
their decision and how they're raising
their kids so they can take them to a
drag queen story hour at the public
library if they want to or maybe a
private library if they want well the
issue the issue i take with with drag
queen story hour is that drag is a
sexualized performance and and that's
literal grooming so let me ask you this
in response do you think a parent should
should bring their kids to go go dancer
story hours no not a drag queen i don't
think that's exactly right i don't think
they should take a drag queen story hour
but i mean there is some kind of a line
there where what you're saying is you
know if if the parent wants to teach the
child about it let's say the child is
gay you know they want to have a
conversation with them about it and they
say that the boy wants to dress up like
a woman what is a safe environment that
a parent can introduce them to those
concepts that wouldn't become grooming
if drag is inherently sexual right well
i mean but i mean like it's a community
right the gay community is a community
and there's got to be some kind of a
safe way for parents to be able to you
know if a child is asking them to
educate them i mean what do you do lock
them away in the tower and rapunzel it
down the hair when they're 18 and all of
a sudden they can be introduced to that
community or they're going to go online
and they're going to be introduced to
that community in a way that might be
damaging to them might be more harmful
to them if they can't be introduced away
i don't know and i'm not advocating for
drag queen story hours i'll tell you
that we don't know i'll tell you what's
a healthy way to do this i don't know
the answer i i agree with your with with
with uh uh
the premise
you know kids who are lgbt need a safe
environment to to talk about and learn
about these things but i will also say
that as someone uh you know my family
owned a cafe in north halsted in chicago
which is boys town
yeah it's a gay community and everything
was overtly sexual the the storefronts
were sexualized the products they sold
were were sexualized macaroni and cheese
and on display in the window was was was
genitals uh the mannequins were
anatomically correct and performing acts
on each other so this is that's not a
safe place to bring a kid you're right
and my brother and i've been having this
conversation just like in the last few
weeks about he is sick and tired of of
drag queens becoming the avatars for the
gay community like why is it that pride
has to be this sexualized event why
can't it be something that can include
conservative gays why is it and it is
and you know and uh
it's it's it's notorious at pride events
people walk around naked
uh women topless and all these things i
would not call that a safe environment
for a child to learn about these things
correct so when you have drag for
instance you have a lot of people left
saying it's just it's just dress-up it's
costume it's like okay what is a drag
performance a person in a sexualized way
uh acts provocatively and it's
accentuating sexual features and accepts
money either in the thong or in in their
and they rip their clothes off
they had uh desmond is amazing a little
boy ripping his clothes off on stage for
tips
that is the same thing as stripping
and they acknowledge this that drag
shows incorporate the crowd giving money
to the performer as they do these things
so
you say drag i say go go dancing or
stripping i don't see it any different
inappropriate for kids there's a new
twitter account called gays against
grooming that's right ariel scarcella
good good oh i didn't know that was her
okay yeah but now she's involved but for
every reaction there's going to be an
equal counter reaction there's going to
be conservative gays who are going to
come out they're going to say this and
you know people like that should be able
to have a seat at the table at the texas
gop i know that's been a big question
lately so if we don't encourage the
conservative gays
to speak out in their that community and
offer them some kind of a moral support
then they're going to continue to be
drowned out by those people who will
sexualize children so how we do that is
if is a challenge because if you're a
conservative you know many people in the
movement are not going to be in favor of
interacting with the gay community at
all this is again the state of texas
republican party is having this big
fight right now over whether or not log
cabin republicans will be included right
so we need to have allies in that
community in order to have inroads with
that community if you really want to
protect kids that's going to have to be
a front a battlefront that we're going
to have to participate in i disagree on
that one so
i think that as soon as and you were
sort of talking about the slippery slope
earlier and societies are going to pass
their values on they're going to pass
their values onto their children and
also when you start breaking down taboos
it's not as if the people who want to
break down taboos are ever satisfied
they just keep pushing for the next
thing and i think that's sort of always
been the agenda behind the sexual
revolution going back to kinsey
and john money who i've talked about
extensively on the show and what their
goals were and they quite literally said
and this is kinsey who is the the called
the godfather of the sexual revolution
he is the person who is credited as
being the founder of the modern study of
sex or sexology and he openly said that
he thinks the only uh perversion that
exists is chastity in his book he he was
um complicit in the sexual abuse of
children and published data tables in
his literature which basically were
obtained through the sexual abuse of
children i won't get into detail on
exactly what it was uh just because it's
graphic and disgusting but the agenda of
this sexual revolution has always been
to break down all the cultural taboos
and that's not to say that every single
person participating or every single
person who is having sex outside of
marriage or engaging in homosexual
activity wants the movement to reach
that final end but that is its purpose
and we've given it a tremendous amount
of momentum as a society so i don't
think the solution to that is for the
conservative movement which needs to
stand up to it to say we need to
incorporate more behaviors which are
just non-traditional sexual activities
that we historically viewed as
perversions into our own fold to help us
make our power but conservatism is a
blanket term and it's or it's an
umbrella term that will incorporate many
different philosophies national defense
conservatism social cons it's not just
about social conservatism so there's
also but there's also fiscal
conservatives right so we're going to
have to find some kind of a balance
between these three forces thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there
you